What is a great book?
What I want to show you in this class
is that a great book is something that
makes you fully human by revealing to
you the secrets of the universe and the
secrets of what it means to be human.
Now in school you've been taught that a
person
comes from evolution,
right? We evolve from monkeys.
99% of our of our DNA is that of a
chimpanzee.
And you're taught that the world is
primarily materialistic.
The world is what you can see, what you
can observe, what you can measure, and
that's it. And this is the great lie,
the great deception that we teach you in
school. And we know it's a lie. It's a
deception because everything that you've
taught, you've been taught in school,
everything that you will that you've
learned here, that you will learn in
university, in graduate school, in
science, in life, does not answer a
fundamental question.
What is consciousness?
Why do we see
the world
the way it is? How do we think? How do
we have ideas? How do we communicate?
You're not allowed to ask this question.
And therefore, you're not allowed to ask
a question. What does it mean to be
human? What is human?
Okay. And I will show you in this class
that there are two aspects of being
human.
There is of course the material aspect.
You have a body, but you also have a
soul. Okay? You also have a soul
that connects you to the spiritual
or the divine.
Okay?
And that's who you are. And the
spiritual divine, there's a spark inside
of you that comes from God.
And this spark is what allows you to
love and to imagine. So being a human
means to engage in two fundamental acts.
The act of love of loving someone which
allows you to unify with God and the act
of imagination
to expand your consciousness which
allows you to be God itself. Okay. Love
is the unifying force of the universe.
The God force. The imagination is the
animating force of the universe. And
this is the great secret of the
universe. The universe is not material.
It is conscious. is conscious itself.
Okay. So this is a really hard concept
to
um understand. Okay. So let's work
through it slowly.
Okay. So we have Emanuel K
and we'll read Emanuel K later on. Okay.
Um and he's trying to figure out what
reality is. How do we perceive reality?
And his solution is this.
[clears throat]
He believes that the world is divided
into reality itself called a nana.
Nana just means the things in
themselves, the objective reality.
And then there is the phenomena.
[clears throat]
And what we do basically is that we
perceive or we engage with the nana and
we translate it into the phenomena.
The things in themselves become the
things to us the things that appear to
us. And we do this by filtering the nana
through time and space.
Okay. So our brains are constructed in a
way that allows us to perceive the
spiritual and turn it into material.
Um so another man named Julian James
he is a American psychologist
and he takes his idea and he gives it a
physical basis. Basically what he says
is that our brains have both a right
hemisphere and a left hemisphere.
Okay. Right.
Left. So what the right hemisphere does
is it connects to the nana the things in
themselves that we can never know and
then the left translates it into the
phenomena. Okay. So this is a mechanism
in the brain that does this. The right
hemisphere gets all this information
from the nomen the spiritual and then
the left brain for our eyes for senses
translates into the um phenomena. Okay.
Are we clear? All right. So another
question then is oops.
Okay. So another question then is what
is the nomen? Okay. And this is a
question that mystics,
monks have been struggling with for all
human history. Okay? And so we can never
describe the nana because it is beyond
space and time. It's beyond our capacity
to describe it. So I I can only explain
to you metaphorically.
Okay. What the numinina really is is
consciousness.
Consciousness comes from en energy
vibrations.
Okay? So all the entire universe it's
Vibrations
carry information. Information becomes
consciousness. All right. So let's so
let's metaphorically what we say is
there's a source called a monad. Okay.
The one okay the center of the universe
God. And how the monad works is through
breathing emanation [snorts]
[sighs and gasps]
and this creates vibrations
throughout the universe.
Okay. So the mona [clears throat]
breathes in and breathes out and this is
the basis of the universe these
vibrational fields. Okay.
But through this process,
this also creates other entities as
well.
Okay? And we call these the diads.
And
so these are all
the basic structure of the universe. And
then the diets create other forces as
well. Okay. [clears throat]
And as the universe
keeps on vibrating the vibrations, the
frequencies become slower, right? You go
from high ah to low
and because it's going slow now
physicality, materialism develops. This
creates the material universe.
Okay. [clears throat]
But the thing to understand is that
material is always connected to the
spiritual. This entire force, the entire
universe, it's all interconnected
together. It's both everything and
nothing at the same time.
Okay. [snorts]
>> [clears throat]
>> The problem though is that
eventually our world is created
[clears throat] and then what happens is
our world is materialistic
and we have bodies.
So our bodies are part of this material
world but our consciousness comes from
the divine.
Okay, does that make sense? So our
bodies are are created through evolution
but our consciousness is created through
the vibrations of the universe. Our
consciousness is connected with the
universe itself.
Right? So another way we can understand
this concept is imagine these people
together. Okay? You have all these
people together.
So how consciousness works is it's an
infinite dimensional
consciousness. So this is what happens
right your consciousness is expanding
infinitely into the universe. As you can
see at one level you are by yourself.
Okay your consciousness is is unique to
you but [snorts] another level at higher
level is that you're connecting with
someone else.
And then you're connected to another
person. Okay? And you go on and on until
you connect with everything.
So within your consciousness is a
capacity
to connect with the entire universe, but
it's really far far away. Okay.
Okay. So this is complicated. And so
different philosophers throughout
history have tried to figure out how to
best articulate this truth, this great
secret to humanity. And the best
metaphor that we have is something
called Plato's allegory of the cave.
Plato's cave.
And this helps us understand who we are,
where we came from, and where we're
going. Okay. So this is a metaphor, an
allegory that helps us understand what
it means to be human and the human
condition. Okay? So what Plato says is
this. Imagine you have these prisoners.
Okay? And they're all tied down. They're
chained to the ground. Their necks are
chained. Their arms are chained. So you
can't move your head. You can't get up.
Okay? And what you're doing is you're
watching a wall. Okay, this is a wall.
[snorts] And behind the wall behind you
is this great fire. And then from behind
this fire are these people. We don't
know who they are actually, okay? But
they are putting up these figures. And
so they are projecting shadows onto a
wall. And because we the prisoners
cannot see
the entirety of a reality, we believe
that the war itself is reality.
Okay. So, so an example of this of
course is movies. We watch movies and we
think this is reality.
Okay. So the question then is
why are these people
making this effort
to fool us into believing that this wall
these movies are real? And the answer is
because they're trying to enslave us.
Okay,
slavery.
But then you're like, "Okay, but slavery
means that I take a gun and I say, if
you don't do what I say, I'll kill you."
[snorts]
But that's not what slavery is. If the
cons, if the universe is conscious,
okay, our energy
comes from our attention.
Attention is energy.
So what they want is our energy.
[clears throat]
Okay, that's true wealth. If they're
able to focus our energy, capture
imagination, they can construct reality
in the way that they want it. Okay?
Because reality is what we imagine it to
be. The imagination is the animating
force of the universe.
Right? So if they can focus our
attention
for us, they can create their own
reality.
All right? Now we understand why we
watch movies. Now we understand why we
have the internet. Now we understand why
the school wants you to love artificial
intelligence because it's to enslave
you. It's all of human history is about
enslavement.
Okay? That's what progress is. You think
that oh my god I can now watch movies.
Oh my god I have now social media. I can
communicate with anyone. Oh my god, I've
chat GBT and TBT can tell me the truth
about the world. No,
all these things are created to enslave
your mind
because you have access to God.
And so what they're trying to do is
trick you
into believing that this reality is a
true reality. Because once you believe
that this reality becomes the only
reality.
Okay. So then the question is like who
are these people? Well, we don't know.
Okay. You can say they're the elite.
They're the power side be. You can also
say they're demons. We don't know. Okay.
But they're interested in fooling us
in believing into believing that the
movies that we see are real. The
internet is real. Social media is real.
Okay. So then the question then is okay
if this is slavery what is freedom?
All right. [clears throat] What freedom
is
is to escape this system
and to be able to think for yourself to
see for yourself to be yourself. So
Plato goes on and says, "Okay, this one
guy, for whatever reason, his chains
break loose and he stones out out of the
cave into the wilderness." Okay, the
wilderness. And he sees the sun and son
of course is God. And at first he's
blinded by the light. Uh yes, you have a
question.
>> Oh yeah. So So let
>> Sorry. Um
yeah. Can you can you speak into the
microphone please?
>> So uh I have a question before like we
talk about the freedom because like uh I
>> Yeah. Can I first explain what freedom
is?
>> Okay. Sure. Thanks.
>> Thank you. All right. All right. It it
it'll it all makes sense. Okay. All
right. All right. So you go out into
the world and at first you're blinded by
the light. Okay. and you hate it, but
you struggle. And then you you teach
your eyes to see.
And then you recognize that this world
is beautiful.
It is infinite. It's diverse. It's
alive. This world that you thought was
real, it's just a corpse. It's a dead
zombie world. Okay? This is what life
is.
Okay? And that's what freedom is.
Freedom means that you are now finally
able to awake from this terrible
nightmare. See everything that is around
us, movies, the AI school
as prison,
as a as hell.
And then you're able to look inside
yourself and then connect back to God.
Okay.
the spiritual to look beyond the
phenomena and return to the nana
to peer into the nana which is
vibrations energy. Okay. All right. So
that's clearly of the cave. This makes
sense right? Now this raises a question
which is okay that's fine but how do we
escape? Okay. How do we seek freedom?
Okay. So
if you look at every single
religious tradition whether it's
Buddhism, Hinduism,
Dowoism,
Christianity, Judaism, doesn't matter.
Okay? Every single religion proposes the
same solution which is meditation.
Okay. What is meditation? Okay. Let's
All right. So, let's start. If the world
is vibration, if it flows,
there must be a logic to this flow.
There must be a certain structure to
this movement. Okay? And the Egyptians
proposed that what governs this flow is
the idea of sacred geometry.
Okay, sacred geometry. Okay, this is
what DJ has spent thousands of years
figuring out that the vibrational energy
flows in certain geometric patterns.
Okay. And these geog gem geometric
patterns are the basis for the universe
itself.
So now if we understand this sacred
geometry, what we can we can do now is
construct our conscious in a way that
allows us to match
the vibrational flow of the universe.
Okay? To harmonize with the universe,
right? And how do you do that? You do
that through breathing. Okay? Brea
breath work.
[snorts] Because by breathing you're
going to structure your consciousness in
a way that becomes part of the universe
itself.
All right? And this will take decades.
But you can do this. And then when
you're able to harmonize with
vibrational flow of the universe,
then reality itself reveals itself to
you. Okay? You're able to see this world
as false. you're able now to connect to
the true spiritual universe.
Okay. Um so this is true consciousness
and this is what all monks in the world
are trying to do.
Okay? You're trying to leave your body
and embrace the spiritual because when
you do that it allows you to connect
with the divine and discover the secrets
of the universe. You're able to see both
the phenomena as well as the nana. Okay.
And this is a great secret of all
religions. This is what all religions
practice.
At the same time there are actually some
hacks. Okay.
hacks.
So, meditation is what you're supposed
to do. But a lot of people are like, you
know what, this is a long time, like
decades and decades of isolation of just
meditation of trying to figure out how
to connect the universe. Okay, that's
decades and decades, possibly 100 years.
There must be an easier way. And there
are. Okay, they're not great, but there
are and we figured it out. Okay, so the
first hack that you can use is
psychedelics.
Right? So these drugs and they could be
magic mushrooms, they be Iaska,
pote, whatever. Okay? But they alter
your conscious in a way that disrupts
your left hemisphere and allows you to
focus on your right hemisphere, which
allows you to see the nomen. Okay? When
you see the nana, you're like, "Oh my
god, it's just energy." Okay? It's just
colors, colors, colors. So if you go
online and you see artwork from people
who've used psychedelics, you will see
that it's very colorful, okay? And it's
very strong. It's all vibrational. Okay?
So that's one hack. Another hack that
you can use is um
um self-denial.
Okay? So it's possible you can starve
yourself fasting. Okay? It's possible
that you go out naked in the cold. Okay.
But when you collapse your body and
you're approaching death, your
consciousness shifts into the spiritual.
Okay. So what's important to understand
is death is at the end. Death is
released because this world that we live
in, our bodies are the prison. Okay? So
don't fear death. It's just part of the
of the natural cycle. Okay. And the
third is uh something called NDEs,
near-death experiences. So these are
people who don't want
to die, but they might be in a car
accident or they could have drowned.
Okay? And they died for like 5 minutes.
What happens? And they all come back and
say the same thing. When they die, they
escape into the spiritual realm and they
meet God.
Okay?
And these are people who don't know each
other, but they say the same thing about
the ne near-death experience, which is
the world that they go into. It is
Plato's world. It's like escaping the
cave and going to the world of the
light. It is a world of p of compassion,
of love, of forgiveness. It is as though
you're connected again with the divine.
Okay.
All right. Um and then
but there's also another way
um and this is what the Christians
believe. Okay, so let's talk about
Jesus.
So Christians, mystics believe that
there's a way
for Jesus to connect fully with the
divine.
Okay. And this is the idea of the Christ
consciousness.
Okay. Okay. So, um I'm going to explain
slowly how this works, but it's very
complicated. Okay. So, interrupt me if
this is confusing.
All right. So, what's important to
understand is that we're not just
passive
observers of reality. We're active
participants in reality. That's why Kant
teaches us. Okay. [snorts] So as we are
um receiving all these vibrations, we
ourselves are vibrations are vibrating
okay for our imagination. Does that make
does that make sense? So as we are
receiving information which allows to
create memories, we then implant our
memories into this consciousness which
changes the universe. So think of the
internet, right? You have a computer,
you have a laptop. It works because it
connects to the internet. It's receiving
information from the internet but then
you change this information it goes back
into the internet. Okay. So through
memories through the con of memories you
are participating in the in the
universe. Okay. All right. But another
another metaphor that we can use is
think of an ocean.
Think of an ocean right and all these
pebbles
are dropping the ocean which creates
vibrations. You are that pebble. Okay.
And your role in the world is to create
as much of a splash as possible. Okay?
To vibrate. The Greeks have a term for
this called udeimmonia, which is the
purpose of life is to be your creative
best. To flourish, to blossom, to
imagine, to vibrate as much as possible.
Okay. So why this is important is that
if we all at the same time imagine
something to be true, it becomes true.
Okay? So who's the most famous person in
the world? Jesus, right? So Jesus is
immortal. He's eternal because there are
two billion people in the world who love
him, who imagine him all the time, who
believe that he's part of their lives.
And because of their imagination,
Jesus still is still with us today, but
he's at a high vibration. Okay. All
right. So, he's a high vibration. Jesus.
Then the question is,
how do you resurrect Jesus? How do you
bring him back? And the answer is by
making your body a vessel for Jesus to
return in. Okay? Your body can become a
portal for Jesus to inhabit, to possess
if you welcome Jesus through certain
spiritual practices. Okay? Including
love, generosity, forgiveness.
All right? If if someone killed your
son, you may hate that person, but if
you're able to forgive that person and
show true forgiveness, because listen,
if someone killed my children, I'd be
pissed off. Okay? I I I would hate that
person forever. But if you're able to to
yourself
forgive that person of your own free
choice,
you open yourself up to divinity. Okay?
And this divinity can now flow into you.
And this is what we call the Christ
consciousness or the second coming of
Jesus.
So if you are a Christian, you believe
the second coming there that Jesus will
return. And Christian mysterious believe
that yes, he can always return if you
open your heart to Jesus. But you have
to construct your body, your mind, your
conscious in a way that allows for Jesus
to inhabit you.
Okay? So this is the secret of the
universe.
The world, the universe exists in our
consciousness.
The consciousness is what's real. The
material is what's false.
And as we imagine, we participate in in
the universe, we change the universe.
And we focus
on a certain reality, that reality
becomes manifest. It becomes reality
itself.
Okay?
And by living in the memories of others,
we become immortal like Jesus.
And by constructing our lives
in a way that allows for Jesus to
return, we can resurrect Jesus in
ourselves. Okay? So that's a good
secret. Secret of the universe. This is
a secret to immortality,
reincarnation,
and godhood.
Okay, these three things
and most of us will fail but it's it's
okay because why? Because our conscious
is forever. So reincarnation means that
when we die we can escape back to the
spiritual and then maybe a thousand
years later we come back. Okay? So it's
a constant cycle where we're trying to
achieve these three things. Immortality,
reincarnation, and godhood. And the
secret is love
powering our imagination. Okay, we're
here to imagine things.
Okay, so this is a great secret of the
universe. This is a secret that
religions have passed on through
thousands of years of human history and
which schools, science, government, all
the powers that be try to suppress
because is a direct threat to this
reality. Okay, this reality is false.
But they want to make it real because
they derive power from this reality.
Okay, does that make sense, guys? Okay,
everything that you've been taught in
school, everything that you've learned
in science class, it is complete and
utter nonsense. This is what's true.
Okay. Okay. So now that we understand
all of this,
we can also understand the great books
because what I will show you this
semester is if you truly want to achieve
these three things, immortality,
reincarnation, godhood, the secrets lies
in the great books. The great books are
constructed in a way that allows you to
access the entire secrets of the
universe.
Okay. [snorts] So what the great books
are it is a capturing
of the universe in a state
and as a result there's a universe
within the great books and by embracing
the great books by letting the great
books come into you and then you enter
the great books you have the capacity to
travel in a new universe but you also
have the capacity now to create your own
universe.
And that's what the great books are,
okay? They are the secret of what it
means to be human. They provide the
secret of how to be truly fully human.
All right? And we and what we'll do is
this.
We This is not meant to be, okay, a
semester later on, like 3 months from
now, oh, you'll be immortal, you'll be
God. No, no, that's not the way it
works. Okay?
What I will show you is a path. But it's
up to you to focus and sacrifice
yourself on this path into
enlightenment. Okay. Metaphor a simple
analogy is everyone knows swimming is
the best exercise in the world, right?
Well, if I if I just say go swim doesn't
mean you learn how to swim in one day.
It'll take you decades to learn how to
swim really well.
We all know meditation is really good
for you, right? But it'll take you
decades to fully learn how to meditate
well. Okay. So, this is a journey that
is lifelong, but it's a journey that
requires sacrifice. It's a journey that
requires you to fully learn the great
books. I can't teach you all the great
books. I can't teach you all the secrets
of the great books. I can only give you
a framework.
Okay?
And you must abandon this material
reality that is false. Okay? Abandon
money, power,
sex, fame and focus on embracing the
great books. And when you do that,
the universe comes into you. Okay?
Christians want to be possessed by
Jesus. They want Jesus to enter them and
resurrect Jesus, create the Christ
conscious in them. What we what we want
to do is we want to welcome the greatest
minds of human civilization, the
prophets of our time, the prophets of
human humanity, including Homer, Plato,
Dante caught into our consciousness so
we can be fully human.
Okay? So, we're going to do what the
Christians want to do, but instead of
Jesus, we'll have Homer,
Dante,
uh, Kant, Plato, and anyone else you
want. Okay? Who like it's your choice
who you want to come and possess you,
who want to come and enter you. Okay?
You have now you now I will teach you
the power, the secret to resurrect Homer
and Dante inside of you. But again,
first of all, it's your choice. Second
of all, you must abandon the world to do
this. And third of all, you must
dedicate your entire life to do to doing
this. Okay? So, this class is just meant
to be a sample.
Okay? But it's not meant to
provide all the answers.
Okay? Any questions?
>> So, you have a question. Yeah.
>> So, nice.
Yeah. So, so like uh so back to the
model you drew on the uh on the screen
about the wall and the shadow. So, so
for people who you said be be slaves and
uh like for the people who create a
shadow that they are trying to to create
the reality for those uh people who who
who was called slave. But for those
slaved people that they think this is
like the the shadow on th those things
are the reality and those things uh for
them are the phenomena of the world. So
like, so how could they like to to
escape them and to chase the the real
not not the uh
>> Okay, I understand. Okay. Okay. You you
don't really understand what's going on.
Okay. All right. Let let me explain
explain. Okay.
>> Okay. You you think you know, okay, but
you don't know what's really happening.
Okay.
>> All right. These prisoners,
they're the ones who have the capacity
to create reality. Okay. You understand
this? Now the powers behind them. These
people have the power create reality. So
what I need to do is trick them into
creating the reality that I want them to
create. Does that make sense? Okay. So
these are the powers that be
and they hide in the shadows and they
give you tricks. They use deception,
manipulation
in order to trick you into thinking that
you're a slave.
into tricking you into wanting to create
a reality that they want you to create
but which you think you want to create.
Okay? And that's how the world works.
The we are the ones with the power of
God. We're the ones with imagination.
The ones behind us don't have an
imagination. They have power. They don't
have but they don't have imagination.
Okay? So they need to trick us into
wanting to create the world they want us
to create. And this is how the world
works, guys, right? Why are you in
school being a slave? You say, "I'm not
being a slave. I'm being free. I'm in
school so I can get into a good college,
make a lot of money, and live a happy
life."
Okay? You've been tricked.
But the truth is, no, no, no. You don't
need money to be happy. You don't need
anything to be happy. You have yourself.
Okay? You have your imagination. You
have the capacity to love anyone. If you
just love your mother, if you just love
your father, if you love everyone around
you, you'll be happy. You don't need
money. You're like, "No, no, no. I need
I need a billion dollars to buy my
brother a Porsche. I I I I need to buy
my mother a yacht. That's what my mother
really wants." You've been tricked.
Okay? That's how the world works.
So, it's really easy.
Just say to yourself, I'm a slave and I
refuse to be a slave. I refuse to listen
to what everyone tells me. And that's
the hardest thing to do in the world
because like it would mean your
rejection from reality, right? It would
mean, oh, I have no more friends. My
parents hate me. I'm a loser. Everyone
makes fun of me at school.
All right.
So that's the reality we live in. We
fear social isolation.
We fear being laughed at. So we just go
with the flow even though in our hearts
we know this is all a lie. This school
what the teachers teach us it's all
nonsense. Chat GPT it's lying to us all
the time.
seeking money is going to make me
unhappy. Why am I seeking money? Not for
yourself. Because you fear social
condemnation. You fear being laughed at.
That's why you want money. That's why
you want to do well in school. Once you
accept that, you are free. Can you do
that? No. No. No. You can't do that
because all your life you've been
brainwashed into thinking like the thing
you see is what's real.
Okay. through movies, through school,
through parenting, through friends,
through reality.
Okay? So, that's what Plato's algorith
teaches us.
So, guess what guys, you'll probably
fail, but if you're able to succeed,
you'll be truly free and happy and
imaginative,
and that will allow you to ascend into
immortality.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, there's the state of being free and
the state of being enslaved. Can there
be a slave? Can there be a slave that
consciously realizes that they're being
enslaved and also consciously refuses to
go out to like embrace freedom?
>> Sorry. That that's what a slave is
though, right? A slave is someone who
wants to be a slave, who chooses to be a
slave because all it's all choice. It's
all free will, right? I cannot make you
do this. I cannot ma I cannot make you
force you to lie to yourself. You have
to you have to choose to lie to
yourself. You understand?
Don't think you're being coerced. Don't
think you are being enslaved. You choose
to come to school. You choose to be to
be lied to. You choose to accept the
things as they are. Free will is the
number one principle of the universe.
Okay? When you say like, I'm I'm forced
to be a slave, you're lying to yourself.
It's it's always been your choice.
Okay? Does that make sense?
It's always been your choice.
These prisoners,
they I mean, like they can't break those
chains. They probably could. Okay. And
what [snorts] do you think is going to
happen when this guy who's seen the real
world, when he comes and tells everyone,
"Hey guys, I've seen the real world.
Let's get out of here." What's going to
happen to him? They're going to kill
him. Right? That's what Plato says. If
you dare speak the truth and people know
the truth, they will kill you for
speaking the truth.
All right? So, don't try to convince
anyone of the truth.
Just know the truth for yourself and be
free yourself. But you can never ever
convince someone who doesn't want to
listen. Okay? Don't try it. You'll just
they'll just kill you.
Okay. Uh did you have a question?
Does that make sense? Okay. So, this is
really important for you to understand.
It's always been your choice. But it's
easier for you to think, "No, no, it's
not my choice. I've been coerced. It's
not my choice to come to school. It's
not my choice to uh go get a job because
I if I don't get a job, I'm I'm going to
starve.
No, you won't. Okay?
And remember, in the real world,
death doesn't really mean anything.
Okay? Death just means a release.
It's you tricked yourself into thinking
that death is the worst thing that could
happen to you. When in reality, it's
slavery that's the worst thing that can
happen to you. You fear death but you
are living death right now.
Okay. And that's what the great books
will teach you.
Yeah.
What about the subjective physical
feeling of pain in reality?
>> Oh, okay. Yeah.
All right. Yeah. So, [panting]
the question is why do we feel pain and
why do we have bodies?
And the reason why is that the universe
is constructing a way to promote
imagination. Okay? Because the universe
what it's trying to do is vibrate more.
Vibrate more just means imagine more.
[clears throat]
And if you can't feel pain, if you can't
suffer, if you can't lose, if there's no
evil, you can't imagine things. It
doesn't make sense, right? If everything
was so easy,
nothing would ever have any meaning.
Okay? So, let's just say you want a
really good body and you go to the gym
and then you know you just drink some
water, you just lie around for like 10
hours and then you have this amazing
physique. Well, that would that would
that would just not be beneficial to
anyone. Okay? If you want to
have meaning, you have to struggle for
it and that requires pain and suffering.
So, even though Yeah. The question is
like if if this world is one of death of
one of pain, one of suffering, why are
we in this world? To improve our
imagination. Okay? Because only through
pain and suffering can you truly achieve
your full potential as a human. That's
why these monks meditate for decades in
the snow because they understand that
pain is what allows you to focus your
mind. Okay. Without evil, there can be
no good. If everyone's good, then like
what's the point of being good? It's
only when everyone is evil and you
choose to be good. That's what gives
meaning to your life.
That's what gives meaning to universe.
Okay?
Does that make sense? All right. Any
more questions?
Okay. And again, I know this sounds kind
of strange, but you actually read the
great books. First of all, you will
recognize that's what they're saying.
But also, what's more important is
they're going to give you the energy,
the strength, the power to liberate
yourself if you truly open your heart to
the great books. Okay. So, um the great
books we will start with is the Iliad by
Homer. Then we'll go to the Odyssey by
again by Homer. Then the Republic
uh by Plato. The Iniad by Virgil, which
is not a great book by the way, but we
have to read it anyway. Okay. And then
Divine Comedy by Dante. And then I'll
figure out some other books we can read
depending on how things go. Okay. So, I
like to read K the critic of pure of
pure reason, but uh we may not have
time. Okay. So, that's a plan for the
semester.